because you mentioned AI is there
hope that AI might be able to
help find some interesting insights I
mean another question another way to ask
this question is how special are humans
that we're able to discover novel
insights about the
world that's a great question um and it
depends what kind of insights and we're
going to find that out I mean you know
it's because it's hard to think about
something that doesn't quite exist yet I
mean I could just think about something
take a step back you know it's a little
bit like to understand three four
dimensions you go back to three
dimension you know so to go to something
you can imagine so you can sort of say a
lot of the things in a very different
level about the internet you can say you
know has the internet helped do things
and that you know it definitely took on
a life of its own in some sense but it's
also something that we're able to tame
you know I know that I myself wouldn't
have been able to write books if the
internet didn't exist because I wouldn't
have had the time to go to the library
and look everything up and um it helped
me enormously and in some sense AI could
be that in a very nice World it could be
a tool that helps us go a step further
or than we would and a lot more
efficiently and it's already done that
to some extent or it could be like the
parts of the internet that we can't
control that are ruining politics or
whatever so and there's certainly a lot
of indications that can do that then
there are even bigger things that you
know people speculate about about AI
being able to do its own things but in
terms of actually figuring things out um
you know we're in the early
stages yeah there's several directions
here one is like on the theorem side so
wol from alpha where everything is much
more precise and when you have large
language model type of
stuff one of the limitations of those is
it seems to come up with convincing
looking things which we don't know if
it's true or not right and that's a big
problem for physics so large language
models are more or less like
generalizations of stuff that we have so
the question is so there's still
breakthroughs in AI waiting to happen
and maybe they are happening and maybe
they'll be good maybe not but that
that's not quite the same I mean maybe
to some in some cases it's just pattern
recognition that leads to important
things but sometimes it could be
something more insightful than that that
I can't even put my finger on so it
forces us to I mean we don't really
understand how smart we are we don't
understand how we think about things all
that well actually but one thing is true
that we are a lot more efficient right
now than computers and coming up with
things we require a lot less energy to
do that so if computers figure out how
to do that then it's going to be a
totally different ball game so and so
there are clearly kinds of connections
that we don't know how we're making but
we are making them and so that's going
to be interesting so um you know I say
we're in early stages but this is
changing very
rapidly but right now I don't think that
it's actually you know discover like new
laws of physics but could it in the
future maybe it can it will raise big
questions
about what is special about humans that
we don't quite appreciate you know with
there could be things that are like
that leap of insight that happens truly
novel ideas that could potentially be
very difficult to
do so there are sort of abstract
questions like that there's also
questions of how is it that we can
address to some extent you know how will
AI be used in the context of the world
we live in which is based on you know at
least our country is based on capitalism
and a certain political system and how
will global politics deal with it how
will
our capitalist system deal with it what
will be the things that we focus on
doing with it how much will researchers
get control of it um to be able to ask
different sorts of questions I mean you
know while it was starting out people
were doing these kind of toy problems
but what will it actually be applied to
and what will it be optimized to do
there's there's a lot of questions out
there that it's really important we
start
addressing uh what to you
is the most beautiful unsolved problem
in physics and cosmology what you is
really exciting if we can unlock the
mystery of in the next few
decades um so is it what's the most
beautiful unsolved problem or what is
the most beautiful unol problem I think
we can make progress
on oh boy we make progress on in the
next few
centuries there's you know this most of
the questions the big questions have to
do with what underlies things how things
started what's at the base of it there's
also just basic questions like how that
you asked earlier how far will science
take us how much can we understand um
there are questions like how we got here
um what underlies it are there you know
but also I mean there's really deep
questions like you know what fraction
are we actually seeing if there are
these other forces if there is another
way of seeing the world are there G you
know universes beyond their own they're
if there's so different how do we even
comprehend them I mean how do we detect
like what would we even think about them
so there's a lot about trying to get
Beyond it's always just getting beyond
our limited vision and limited
experience and trying to see what
underlies it both at small scales and at
large scales we just don't know the
answers I mean I'd like to think that
we'd understand more about Dark Matter
about Dark Energy about are there extra
Dimensions things that we actually work
on but it's probably a lot beyond what
we work on that's yet to be
discovered yeah understanding the extra
Dimensions
piece will be really interesting totally
I mean if it is you know how the
universe went from higher Dimensions to
what we see do you know are the extra
Dimensions present everywhere I mean you
know one of the really interesting piece
of physics we did that I talk about my
first book War passages is finding out
that there can be a higher Dimension but
only locally do you think there's a
gravity of a lower Dimension so it could
be like only locally do we think we live
in three dimensions it could be higher
Dimensions is different it's not
actually the gravity we have but it
there's all sorts of phenomena that
might be out there that we don't know
about all sorts of evolution things time
dependence that we don't know about um
and of course that's from the point of
view of particle physics from the point
of view of other kinds of physics we're
just beginning so who knows yeah if the
physics changes throughout is is not
homogeneous throughout the universe
that's
that'll be weird I mean you know for the
observable universe it's the same but
beyond the observable universe who
knows